Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec. Mais bonjour. Vous avez été très nombreux à écouter mon échange avec Jean-Marc Jancovici il y a deux semaines.
Vous avez pété tous les records, donc un grand merci à vous. Ravi d'avoir eu tous vos retours. On reste en France cette semaine puisque j'ai eu le plaisir de discuter avec l'excellente Lucie Ronfaut-Hazard de son roman : Les Règles du jeu
et des thèmes qui sont abordés, comme par exemple la place qu'occupent les femmes dans le milieu des start-up tech
ou encore la question des outils numériques pour assister les personnes qui ont leurs règles.
J'espère que ça vous plaira. Let's go ! Et j'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir de recevoir Lucie Ronfaut-Hazard. Bonjour Lucie.
Bonjour.
Lucie, tu es journaliste spécialisée dans les nouvelles technologies et la culture web. Tu as longtemps travaillé pour Le Figaro Tech.
En ce moment, tu es journaliste indépendante. Tu rédiges chaque semaine la newsletter Règle 30, qui parle d'actualité tech de manière féministe et inclusive pour Numerama.
Est-ce que j'ai oublié quelque chose ?
Bah non, écoute, c'est un bon résumé.
Super. Mais donc en plus de tout ça, tu as publié cette année un roman, nommé Les Règles du jeu et qui parle justement de ce que c'est d'être une femme dans cette start-up nation, puisque voilà, ce--
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait résumer cette histoire ?
Donc ce sont quatre femmes qui décident ensemble de se lancer dans un projet de start-up autour des menstrutech.
Tout à fait. Ouais, donc Les Règles du jeu, c'est l'histoire de quatre nanas qui ont 25 ans, qui sont dans cette période de la carrière où
ça a commencé, mais ça a un peu de mal à décoller, donc elles sont un peu paumées pour plein de raisons différentes.
Et l'une d'entre elles a cette idée de lancer une application de suivi des menstruations. Donc moi, j'appelle ça vite fait la menstrutech, mais c'est un mot que j'ai inventé hein, c'est pas un truc qui existe dans le dictionnaire.
Et donc c'est des services qui existent dans la vraie vie hein, c'est des applis qu'on utilise pour, voilà, vérifier quand on a ses règles, quand on ovule, et cetera.
Et donc Alice, mon héroïne, veut lancer une application de menstrutech, mais qui ne soit pas réservée aux femmes qui veulent avoir des enfants.
Parce que ça, c'est un gros enjeu de la menstrutech, c'est que souvent, c'est réservé un peu à la procréation. Donc elle a ses grands idéaux un peu féministes, et cetera.
Elle se dit qu'elle va changer le monde. Elle finit par s'entourer, bon gré mal gré, de trois autres filles qui la rejoignent pour des raisons diverses et variées.
Et en fait, bah l'histoire du roman, c'est un peu toutes les difficultés qu'elles vont rencontrer dans leur parcours.
Parce que déjà, un, lancer une start-up, c'est pas facile, mais deux, garder ses idéaux et encore plus ses idéaux féministes,
quand on lance une start-up, c'est très, très difficile, voire peut-être impossible si on est un peu pessimiste. Voilà.
Mais donc on sent vraiment hein, puisque ça se déroule dans cet écosystème start-up
parisien, on sent vraiment que ton passif de journaliste tech dans cet écosystème start-up a vraiment servi de base et de,
comment dire, de-- ça sera le véhicule, en fait, puisque je parle très peu de mon propre parcours dans ce podcast, mais je pourrais peut-être contextualiser un peu pour celles et ceux qui ne me connaissent pas.
Mais moi-même, en fait, en dehors de ce podcast, je travaille et je vis dans la tech et dans l'univers des start-up.
Et donc celles et ceux qui écoutent ce podcast depuis le début savent que ça a commencé autour des questions du manque de femmes dans ce secteur-là.
Donc on est bien alignés, on se retrouve sur ces problématiques-là. Mais du coup, toi, voilà, on sentait que tu voulais aborder ces sujets.
Pourquoi est-ce que tu as choisi d'en faire un roman et pas un essai, un article, un podcast, un documentaire ? Pourquoi le médium roman ?
Alors, déjà parce que j'ai déjà beaucoup en fait écrit sur le sujet en tant que journaliste. Moi, c'est--
la question de la diversité dans la tech et plus généralement les questions humaines dans la tech m'intéressent beaucoup depuis le début de ma carrière.
Et au Figaro, par exemple, j'avais déjà été amenée à écrire des articles, voilà, sur les clubs pour initier les filles au code, la menstrutech, justement, j'avais écrit sur la menstrutech.
Enfin bon, c'est des sujets qui m'ont toujours intéressée, et qui m'intéressent toujours d'ailleurs hein, parce que comme tu l'as dit, j'ai une newsletter qui est vraiment dédiée à ça hein, la question du féminisme dans la tech.
Cela étant dit, bon déjà un, j'ai toujours écrit de la fiction, en parallèle de mes activités de journaliste, même avant en fait hein, ce que j'écris depuis que je suis petite.
C'est un peu cliché, mais c'est vrai. Et en fait, à un moment, j'ai eu envie d'écrire une histoire un peu plus longue, pas une nouvelle, pas une fanfiction, enfin un truc un peu plus long cours.
Et naturellement m'est venue cette idée en fait de ces nanas qui lancent une start-up. Et en fait, je les relie assez naturellement à mon travail
parce qu'en fait, mes articles, ils étaient lus, ils sont toujours lus, mais par des gens, pas par tout le monde.
C'est-à-dire que je suis pas naïve hein, c'est normal. Déjà un, tout le monde ne lit pas la presse. Deux, tout le monde ne lit pas Le Figaro.
Et trois, tout le monde ne lit pas Le Figaro Économie. Pour mentionner, voilà, là où j'ai longtemps bossé.
C'est-à-dire que mes sujets tech et inclusivité, on peut supposer que les gens qui les lisaient, c'était quand même
globalement des gens qui s'intéressaient déjà au numérique ou à l'économie, et cetera, et qui du coup tombaient sur ces articles, et cetera.
Et en fait, moi, je me suis dit : peut-être que la fiction, ça peut être un moyen de parler aux gens qui s'intéressent pas du tout à ces sujets,
mais qui ont juste envie de lire une histoire sympa quoi, de lire une histoire un peu rigolote, un peu originale.
Et du coup, d'élargir un petit peu, peut-être presque de prendre par surprise en fait mes lecteurs et mes lectrices sur ces sujets.
Donc, et puis en fait, c'était facile pour moi de l'écrire cette histoire parce qu'en fait, le sujet, je le maîtrisais déjà.
Moi, j'ai déjà rencontré beaucoup d'entrepreneuses, de développeuses, enfin de femmes dans la tech qui m'ont raconté plein d'histoires.
Moi, je suis pas entrepreneuse, je suis pas développeuse. Par contre, je suis une femme qui évolue dans le milieu de la tech depuis des années.
Donc bah ça, voilà, j'en ai récolté pas mal d'expérience et de ressenti. Et donc, ouais, ça me paraissait assez naturel d'écrire sur ce sujet, mais du coup, c'était marrant de l'écrire différemment.
Mhm. Et donc cette idée de toucher un autre public, est-ce que ça a fonctionné ? Est-ce que tu as touché cet autre public ?
Parce que comme on le disait, moi, je suis dans le public qui connaissait déjà ton travail avant sur le Figaro.
Donc je me demandais : est-ce que les vrais gens, entre guillemets, les gens qui ne sont pas dans l'écosystème startup ont pu, voilà, être confrontés à ces problématiques grâce à ton livre ?
Écoute, j'ai l'impression, oui. Déjà parce que j'ai eu énormément de retours de lectrices.
Cool.
Ce qui, ça, en tout cas quand je travaillais au Figaro, c'était moins le cas, parce que malheureusement, les sujets tech sont encore considérés par la société en général comme très masculins.
Donc parfois, c'est un peu difficile de parler de ces sujets à un public un peu divers. En plus, j'ai travaillé avec donc ma maison d'édition qui s'appelle La Ville Brûle, qui-- super maison d'édition et qui
traite en fait beaucoup des sujets de féminisme.
Donc y a déjà un public assez intéressé par ces sujets. Et puis y a un truc tout bête, c'est que sur la couverture, y a un énorme tampon ensanglanté et que ça, bah naturellement, je pense que ça a dû écarter
une partie du public masculin qui était pas capable de gérer ce genre de choses.
Donc ouais, ouais, j'ai eu pas mal de retours. Alors, j'ai eu deux types de retours. Soit j'ai eu des femmes qui bossaient dans la tech et ça, c'était super.
'Fin des nanas qui sont venues me voir, qui m'ont dit : « Bah en fait, je l'ai vécu et-
Mhm
...et j'ai trouvé ça réaliste quoi. On pourrait croire que c'est exagéré, mais non, ça l'est pas.
» Et j'ai eu des femmes aussi qui sont venues me voir en me disant : « Bah en fait, moi, jamais je me serais dit que les sujets du numérique ou de la startup, etc., m'intéresseraient.
Et ton histoire m'a plu. » Et ça, pour moi, c'est une grande victoire parce qu'au-delà de parler des startups, je pense que c'est un bouquin-- 'fin, moi, je voulais que ce livre parle du numérique en général.
Et moi, je pense vraiment qu'on n'a pas besoin de travailler dans le numérique pour que le numérique nous concerne, parce qu'on est dans une société en fait actuellement qui est numérisée et qui le sera de plus en plus et qui le sera pas moins.
Et donc on n'a pas besoin d'être un techos, un geek, un entrepreneur, une entrepreneuse. On n'a pas besoin d'avoir les mains dans le cambouis pour avoir un avis sur la tech.
Donc ouais, le fait d'avoir des filles qui m'ont dit : « Bah je m'y intéressais pas, mais ce bouquin, il m'a intéressée.
Du coup, j'ai réfléchi un peu au sujet des données, au sujet du harcèlement, etc. » Bah, c'était... 'Fin c'était, ouais, j'étais super contente.
Mh. Tu disais donc des personnes directement concernées qui lisaient ton livre et qui se reconnaissaient, reconnaissaient leurs expériences passées.
C'est une réflexion que je me suis fait aussi en fait, aussi en lisant le livre. Est-ce que tu as fait des rencontres ?
Est-ce que tu as interrogé ? T'as fait des terrains pour rencontrer les personnes qui ont eu ce genre d'expérience ou comment est-ce que t'as fait pour être aussi proche de la réalité ?
Alors, j'ai pas fait de terrain pour ce bouquin. C'est-à-dire que moi, ça fait sept ans et demi maintenant que je suis journaliste, donc j'ai rencontré beaucoup de gens au cours de ma carrière.
J'ai pas voulu faire de terrain pour ce bouquin parce que c'était très important pour moi de faire une distinction entre mon travail de journaliste et mon travail d'autrice.
C'est une fiction. Y a pas d'événements qui sont-- alors, y a des choses, voilà, qui sont inspirées de la vraie vie.
Voilà, par exemple, à un moment, les filles se font emmerder par un forum qui s'appelle gaming.com. Pas besoin de beaucoup réfléchir pour savoir à quoi ça fait référence.
Donc voilà, c'est ancré dans la réalité, mais c'est pas la réalité. Et ça, c'était important pour moi. Donc non, j'ai pas fait de terrain, mais après, oui, je pense que je suis bien informée.
J'ai aussi essayé de me mettre à la place de mes héroïnes. Je leur ai aussi mis beaucoup de bâtons dans les roues.
Je pense que l'expérience de mes héroïnes, c'est vraiment l'une des pires qu'on puisse avoir, on va dire, dans le sens où voilà, elles ont vraiment pas de répit, elles ont vraiment toutes les embûches qu'elles peuvent avoir.
Toutes les entrepreneuses et toutes les développeuses, heureusement, n'ont pas autant de difficultés, même s'il y en a quand même pas mal.
Mais voilà, je me suis, 'fin, je me suis amusée. J'ai volontairement peut-être un peu grossi le trait, mais c'est ancré dans la réalité.
Oui, donc c'est ancré dans la réalité, mais ça reste de la fiction. Et y a notamment un parti pris qui est, mais, de la fantasy, de la science-fiction.
Quatre femmes qui lancent une startup. Et en plus, de, voilà, des profils très différents en termes d'orientation sexuelle, en termes de race, en termes de toutes ces choses-là.
Y a une vraie diversité. Chose qui est introuvable. 'Fin, c'est, moi, ça ne se remarque pas. Ou 'fin, ça ne se trouve pas, en tout cas, à moins de vraiment chercher, euh-
Moi, je suis pas d'accord avec ça.
D'accord.
Et je trouve ça intéressant que tu dises : « C'est introuvable, ça ne se remarque pas. » Je pense que ça ne se remarque pas, mais ça se trouve.
C'est-à-dire que, alors oui, effectivement, on entend très peu parler de startups avec que des femmes. Moi, dans mon vécu de journaliste, j'en ai rencontré des femmes comme mes héroïnes.
En fait, j'ai rencontré des développeuses, j'ai rencontré des entrepreneuses, j'ai rencontré des femmes professionnelles qui venaient de milieux très différents.
D'accord.
Voilà, qui, pour le dire très clairement, qui étaient pas toutes blanches, etc., qui avaient pas toutes les mêmes orientations sexuelles.
Je pense que, et j'ai pas la solution à ce problème hein, je le pointe juste. Je pense qu'on a un souci dans la médiatisation de la startup.
Déjà un, bon clairement, y a une survalorisation de la figure masculine, mais ça qui nous vient de, voilà-
De partout, ouais.
Voilà, tu me disais que tu avais reçu Isabelle Collet. Elle en parle beaucoup mieux que moi. Le fait que la tech était avant tout en fait un domaine de femmes au début, dans les années 50, et que les hommes, petit à petit,
sont arrivés dans le milieu et ont un peu pris les places, pour le dire vite.
Donc y a déjà ce souci. Deux, je pense qu'on a tendance à survaloriser la figure de l'entrepreneur seul. C'est la figure du patron qui a une idée formidable dans un garage, qui plaque tout pour la faire, etc.
Et du coup, qui occulte complètement la réalité que des startups, généralement, c'est plusieurs personnes. Et en fait, c'est pas mal d'employés.
Et généralement, cette diversité, en fait, on la trouve chez les employés, moins chez les entrepreneurs.
Mh.
Et donc du coup, tout ça pour dire que je--
oui, la startup que je décris, Rules, serait sans doute une rareté, quelque chose d'intéressant, mais je pense pas que mes héroïnes soient si rares dans ce milieu.
C'est juste qu'on les laisse pas s'exprimer ou alors peut-être qu'elles partent, en fait, du milieu, ce qui est un autre souci.
Ah oui, oui, certainement. Là où on va peut-être se rejoindre, c'est que donc, ce qui frappe, c'est que ce sont donc quatre cofondatrices, donc à l'origine de leur histoire.
Et là, tu dis : « La diversité, on la trouvera peut-être- Dans un second temps, quand il commence à y avoir du, voilà, des employés, des personnes qui viennent se rajouter à l'équipe.
Mais là, on parle de quatre personnes qui doivent avoir
les moyens de se soutenir pendant une longue période de lancement quand on est en période de recherche, voilà, on cherche son modèle économique, on cherche des revenus, on cherche une levée de fonds,
on doit développer des prototypes.
Donc ces choses-là prennent du temps. Et donc de base, la startup, à mon sens, ça reste quelque chose pour les profils assez privilégiés hein.
Et donc c'est pour ça que,
quatre femmes racisées à qui on va dire, enfin non, trois femmes racisées plus une blanche, à qui on va dire : « Mais,
très peu de chances de lever des fonds » et on les refuse même à un incu-- enfin, y a un incubateur qui les refuse au début de l'histoire.
C'est effectivement quelque chose que j'ai jamais vu. Quatre cofondatrices femmes avec des profils aussi variés.
Écoute, oui, encore une fois, enfin comment dire ? Je grossis le trait, mais vraiment, j'insiste, ces femmes existent en fait. Euh-
D'accord
...et je veux dire, y a des startups. Alors, déjà, là où je pense que tu as raison, une startup se lance rarement à quatre personnes, ça c'est clair.
Ouais, ouais.
Et d'ailleurs, j'ai été accompagnée dans l'écriture de mon livre par plusieurs
amis, notamment un qui s'appelle Stan, qui m'écoutera peut-être, qui a lui-même été entrepreneur et qui a lui-même lancé sa startup et qui du coup m'a un peu accompagnée sur le côté assez biz,
pour que ça soit assez réaliste, entre guillemets.
Donc je pense que je suis un peu à la limite du réalisme parfois sur le bouquin, mais quand même, c'est pas complètement absurde.
Par exemple, y a des petits détails, par exemple, qu'est-ce que j'avais mis ? Y a qu'une seule salariée dans la startup, les autres sont en autoentrepreneuriat.
Ce qui, ça, y a un truc assez classique dans le milieu des startups. 'Fin, j'ai essayé de mettre des petits détails quand même qui soient réalistes.
Après, la question, ce que tu me parlais de l'incubateur et du refus de lever des fonds.
Mhm.
Ça, c'était un sujet qui était assez important parce que pour revenir au réalisme, quand on parle de la diversité dans la tech, on parle souvent des femmes qui arrivent dans la tech.
C'est-à-dire, on manque de femmes dans les écoles d'ingénieurs, par exemple, on manque de femmes dans les écoles de commerce, 'fin sur ces structures un peu plus tech, etc.
On parle assez rarement des femmes qui montent leur startup et qui ensuite essayent d'en faire quelque chose. Et ça, par exemple, alors, je sais pas si ça existe en Belgique, mais en France, y a un collectif qui s'appelle le collectif Sista,
qui depuis quelques années fait un peu un,
un peu un observatoire des levées de fonds des startups fondées ou cofondées par des femmes.
Et en fait, c'est assez flagrant de voir à quel point y a des inégalités économiques très importantes entre les startups fondées par des hommes et les startups fondées par des femmes.
C'est-à-dire que voilà, quand on est une femme, alors j'ai pas les chiffres en tête là tout de suite, mais on a beaucoup moins de chances en fait de lever des fonds et de mener sa startup à terme,
que quand on est un homme.
Donc ça, la conséquence, c'est qu'a priori, bah sa startup va mourir beaucoup plus vite qu'une startup fondée par un homme.
Dans un milieu où déjà, vous avez de grandes chances de vous planter dans la première année. Je veux dire, monter une startup hein.
Je la prends pas, le milieu des startups, c'est un milieu qui est assez cruel. Donc ça fait partie, voilà, de ces sujets que je voulais aborder et qui, je pense que, voilà...
Est-ce que les startups de femmes sont rares ou est-ce qu'on les laisse pas vivre en fait ? Et est-ce qu'elles meurent pas avant même d'atteindre le stade où elles peuvent faire l'objet d'articles de presse,
de rentrer dans un incubateur et que juste, bah, elles se prennent des murs dès le départ quoi ?
Clairement. Là, on est tout à fait alignés. Et d'ailleurs, donc on a rapidement cité ce qui arrive donc aux quatre cofondatrices au début du livre.
C'est une d'entre elles va rencontrer, je crois, le directeur ou le boss d'un incubateur. Et puis elle explique : « Ah oui, donc l'équipe est déjà fondée et on est quatre femmes ».
Et au moment où il comprend que ce sont quatre femmes, il change d'avis et refuse. Il retire son invitation en précisant qu'il veut éviter les problèmes de harcèlement sexuel, ce qui c'était très dur à lire.
Est-ce que ça, c'est quelque chose que tu as inventé pour les besoins du roman ou bien est-ce que tu as vraiment été confrontée à ce genre de mésaventure là en rencontrant des startupeuses ?
Alors non, cet événement, il est complètement inventé, dans le sens où en fait, c'est pas tant un incubateur, c'est une hacker house.
Ouais, c'est ça.
Qui moi, un genre de lieu qui me fascine un peu, ce côté, on est que des entrepreneurs, entrepreneuses et on se met dans une maison-
Mmh
...en mode dortoir et on incube, 'fin, on mange, on bouffe, on vit startup. 'Fin, c'est quelque chose, moi, qui me, je l'avoue hein, à titre perso, qui me dépasse un petit peu.
Après, le côté un homme qui va dire à une femme : « J'ai pas envie de bosser avec toi » ou « Je me méfie de bosser avec toi parce que j'ai peur d'être accusé de harcèlement sexuel ».
Ça, pour le coup, c'est quelque chose
qui est pas du tout propre au milieu des startups. C'est quelque chose qu'on peut entendre, je pense, quand on est une femme dans un milieu professionnel et encore plus dans un milieu professionnel dominé par les hommes.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a,
il y a un peu cette réaction à,
peut-être à... Alors, est-ce que c'est à la vague MeToo ou si c'est
en général, hein, une réaction aux prises de conscience sur le sujet du harcèlement sexuel qui provoque des réactions un petit peu débiles comme ça, de se dire
: « Ouh là là, mais qu'est-ce qui va se passer maintenant ?
Je pourrai plus jamais prendre l'ascenseur avec toi, tu vas m'accuser de harcèlement sexuel ? » Bah non. Le plus simple pour ne pas se faire accuser de harcèlement sexuel, c'est de ne pas harceler sexuellement, a priori.
Donc voilà, ça faisait pas référence à un véritable événement, mais... Ce qu'en fait, en règle générale, c'est ce que je dis souvent quand on me demande si le milieu de la tech est beaucoup plus sexiste que les autres.
J'pense que le sexisme au travail, en fait, il existe, il est important, il est là et c'est vrai dans tous les milieux.
Et le milieu de la tech n'est pas différent en ce sens où il s'intègre, voilà, dans ce système patriarcal dans lequel on est tous et toutes.
Néanmoins, ce qui est différent dans le milieu de la tech, c'est que c'est un milieu surdominé par les hommes et qu'en fait, y a pas beaucoup de milieux comme ça.
Des milieux où vraiment les hommes sont extrêmement présents et que du coup, oui, ça,
ça fait un peu un cercle vicieux dans le sens où, déjà, les femmes ont pas mal de bâtons dans les roues avant de devenir en fait développeuses, entrepreneuses, etc.
Et quand elles débarquent, elles sont souvent les seules. Et moi, par exemple, j'ai
J'ai déjà des nanas qui, 'fin des femmes dans le milieu qui m'ont dit : « Bah moi, j'aime bien regarder la photo de la startup qui veut me recruter pour vérifier s'il y a des femmes.
Et s'il y en a plusieurs, j'y vais.
» Sauf que pour qu'il y en ait plusieurs, il faut déjà qu'il y en ait une. Faut déjà qu'il y en ait une qui ait géré peut-être quelques mois, peut-être quelques années d'être la seule nana dans un bureau.
Et peut-être qu'en fait, elle va laisser tomber quoi. Donc, c'est en cela que le milieu, j'pense, de la tech est assez particulier.
Oui, oui. C'est une réponse très proche de ce que m'avait dit justement Isabelle Collet y a trois ans. Ça, j'me souviens qu'à l'époque, ça m'avait fort surpris.
Quand j'avais posé la question de : « Oui, est-ce que le milieu informatique est plus sexiste que les autres ?
» Je m'étais dit : « Bah, bien sûr que oui. Et ça va me permettre d'enchaîner sur toutes ces autres questions. » Elle m'a répondu non et j'étais très surpris.
Mais en fait, oui, c'était juste très naïf de ma part. Et t'as tout à fait raison. C'est juste dans la continuité de tout le reste.
Y a un instant, on évoquait donc cet exemple de la Hacker House qui-- c'était un concept qui te dépassait un petit peu.
J'ai cru que t'allais dire qui te débecte un peu parce que dans le livre, tu es assez dure avec la startup nation en général, les startupers, tout ce monde-là.
Tu n'es pas la seule à tenir ce discours-là. Qu'est-ce qui fait, selon toi, que la startup nation peut entretenir ce côté agaçant, et voilà, et débectant ? Et enfin...
Je pense qu'on est dans une nouvelle phase,
avec la startup nation, comme on dit. 'Fin, alors, quand je parle de la startup nation, c'est vrai que je parle de la startup nation française parce que c'est mon pays, mais bon, c'est applicable-
Oui, c'est la phrase d'Emmanuel Macron, le fameux tweet. Voilà. Mais oui, effectivement. Moi, quand j'emploie ce mot-là, moi, c'est pour dire-
Le milieu
...oui, voilà, le milieu, tout à fait, oui.
Je pense que les startups et le milieu de la tech en général a très longtemps été survalorisé. J'veux dire pendant, allez, on va dire entre,
j'sais pas moi, le milieu des années 2000, le milieu des années 2000 et les années 2015, on va dire.
Y a eu, voilà, cette espèce de-- on avait un peu les étoiles dans les yeux quand on parlait du numérique, de la tech, c'était l'avenir, c'était le...
Donc voilà. Donc y a eu cette survalorisation des startups.
Une bulle.
Oui, peut-être une bulle. Et puis aussi, 'fin, c'était pas très nuancé dans le sens où on valorisait, enfin, on admirait aussi bien Mark Zuckerberg que le moindre type qui voulait lancer une startup.
Ce qui veut pas dire que ce type était forcément une mauvaise personne, mais voilà, y avait un peu une sorte de grand gloubi-boulga autour de la startup nation qui nous a un peu fait oublier un truc, c'est qu'en fait,
y a plein de manières de faire du numérique et y a pas que créer des entreprises.
Et ça, c'est un truc qui est vachement important pour moi. Moi, on m'a déjà dit : « T'aimes pas la tech. » J'ai dit : « Non, si, si moi, j'adore la tech.
» Moi, je baigne dans ce milieu depuis que j'suis petite. J'adore aller sur Internet, j'adore bidouiller, je code un petit peu, etc.
J'aime beaucoup ce milieu, mais je crois que ce milieu ne se limite pas au fait de créer des entreprises. J'veux dire, y a la recherche, y a l'open source, y a plein d'autres choses.
Et je pense que là, on est dans une nouvelle phase de notre relation, au sens large, avec la tech, le numérique, les startups.
C'est que là, on est en train de construire un peu des contre-pouvoirs vis-à-vis de ce milieu. Alors, ça passe par différentes choses.
Ça passe, bon ben, par la fiction. Moi, c'est ce que j'ai essayé de faire avec mon roman. Aux États-Unis, y a la série Silicon Valley qui est super, là, de HBO, que moi, j'adore.
Y a pas mal de bouquins qui reprennent un peu ces thématiques-là. Y a aussi des contre-pouvoirs qui sont journalistiques, c'est-à-dire que voilà,
tous les scandales qu'a pu subir Facebook ces dernières années, comme Cambridge Analytica.
Là, y a de nouveau toute une enquête,
via le Wall Street Journal, etc. Donc y a pas mal d'enquêtes qui sortent en fait, qui viennent casser un peu ce mythe du numérique forcément bienfaisant puisque innovant.
Et puis en France, y a tout un mouvement que je trouve assez intéressant, c'est de revenir sur la startup.
Parce que je pense que le milieu des startups a tellement été survalorisé que du coup, il a un peu,
dépassé le milieu seul de la startup et qu'il y a beaucoup de choses propres aux startups qui sont arrivées dans d'autres entreprises ou dans les milieux professionnels en général.
Rien que dans le vocabulaire, le fait de pitcher des choses, par exemple, le fait de faire des onboardings.
'Fin, y a tout un vocabulaire qui a un peu évolué. La mode des bureaux flottants, 'fin bon, tout ce genre de choses.
Et à côté de ça, on est en train d'en revenir. Et par exemple, moi, j'suis vachement intéressée par le compte Instagram Balance ta startup,
voilà, qui dénonce, qui sert en fait, voilà, de lieu de dénonciation des vrais problèmes RH en fait, hein, qui a lieu dans ces startups et de montrer que bah,
en fait, c'est un milieu qui est très dur et qui malheureusement broie souvent les personnes qui y passent, notamment les employés.
Parce qu'on parle beaucoup des entrepreneurs, mais encore une fois, y a des gens derrière ces entrepreneurs. Et donc voilà, là, on arrive dans une nouvelle phase où on critique enfin ce milieu.
Et moi, je pense que c'est sain, de la même manière qu'il est sain de se moquer et de critiquer et d'enquêter sur les politiques, par exemple, pour parler d'un autre milieu avec du pouvoir.
Le numérique est un milieu qui a beaucoup de pouvoir, et il est bien en fait de le questionner. Ça veut pas dire que tout est à jeter.
Moi, je crois pas que toutes les startups sont nulles hein, c'est pas du tout mon discours. Je dis juste que c'est pas parce que c'est innovant que c'est forcément une bonne chose.
Et c'est pas parce qu'on invente quelque chose dans le numérique qu'on doit forcément faire une startup.
Y a d'autres modèles de possibles. Et je questionne un peu ce côté très cookie cutter en anglais.
'Fin vraiment le côté, on essaye de faire des cookies tous de la même forme. En fait, on peut faire des choses différentes.
On peut faire des choses différentes.
C'est une culture très normative, finalement, de voilà, c'est comme ça qu'il faut faire. Je te suis tout à fait là-dessus.
Cela dit, et désolé d'insister,
je ferais une différence entre la critique donc de ce culte, cette façon dont on idéalise la figure de l'entrepreneur qui fait son truc dans son garage et qui est un petit génie et qui va révolutionner le monde, etc.
Donc voilà, comme tu dis, y a plein, plein d'autres façons de toucher au numérique. Mais ce que je ressens en lisant ton roman, c'est carrément un agacement.
Tu les tournes en ridicule, les personnages qui emploient un certain vocabulaire startup, qui se font des clins d'œil entre eux, et cetera.
On sent un certain agacement par rapport à eux. Est-ce que je me trompe ?
Oui, ben j'les tourne en ridicule, mais en même temps, j'ai de la compassion, je pense. Déjà parce que mes héroïnes, c'est ce qu'elles font.
Elles font une startup. Alors, elles sont mal adaptées à ce milieu qui finit par les rejeter un peu violemment, mais mes héroïnes, elles veulent vraiment faire cette startup.
Et ça, c'est un truc que j'ai beaucoup observé chez les entrepreneurs, c'est que je pense qu'il y a beaucoup d'entrepreneurs et d'entrepreneuses qui veulent authentiquement faire des choses bien.
Ils ont une idée, ils ont souvent des valeurs, et cetera. 'Fin,
c'est rare, heureusement, les gens qui lancent une startup en se disant : « Ha ha ha, j'vais exploiter les données personnelles de mes utilisateurs d'une manière frauduleuse ».
'Fin, c'est pas comme ça que ça marche. Je pense que ce qui se passe, c'est qu'on a un écosystème du numérique qui est conçu d'une seule manière qui est : il faut faire de l'argent.
Parce que c'est des entreprises. En plus, c'est des entreprises en forte tension, donc elles ont besoin de faire de l'argent assez vite.
Donc, voilà, c'est le système du capital-risque, et cetera. Et par exemple, mes héroïnes, elles font une application, une application mobile.
Le modèle numéro un des applications mobiles actuellement, le modèle économique, c'est la publicité. C'est de faire de la pub.
Mais c'est ce qui est vrai pour plein d'autres services en ligne, hein, c'est pas... Et donc, mes héroïnes ont ces grandes idées, mais il leur faut bien un modèle économique un peu viable pour faire marcher leur application.
Et bah du coup, elles mettent en place un système de pub. Et parce qu'elles sont encouragées à aller très vite, elles ont pas le temps en gros de faire les recherches qu'elles devraient faire,
pour mettre un système un peu plus vertueux.
Et elles finissent par, voilà, utiliser les API de Facebook, de Google, 'fin, qui sont des trucs extrêmement banals en fait, hein, dans le numérique.
Et c'est comme ça qu'elles se retrouvent épinglées, parce que bah en fait, les API de Google, les API de Facebook, elles ne sont pas neutres.
Et quand on les utilise, ben on rentre dans un système d'exploitation des données personnelles qui va beaucoup plus loin que ce qu'elles auraient peut-être voulu.
Donc c'était aussi cette histoire que je voulais raconter. C'est des entrepreneurs et des entrepreneuses qui sont bien intentionnés, mais qui sont en fait bouffés par le système qui n'est pas conçu pour fonctionner d'une autre manière.
Et qu'en fait, je pense que c'est dur de faire une entreprise du numérique, une startup, qui fonctionne différemment, qui essaye de garder un peu une certaine éthique dans ce système quoi.
Donc, donc oui, évidemment, je me moque des startupers, je me moque de ce milieu. En fait, je me moque de ce milieu.
Je me moque pas forcément des gens dedans. Alors y en a qui méritent davantage de moqueries, c'est clair. Y en a d'autres, je pense, qui sont aussi victimes de ce système.
Et je pense que c'est dur pour elles et eux.
Je rejoins tout à fait ce que tu dis, mais je m'attendais à une autre réponse dans le sens où la lecture que moi j'ai eue, et qui est peut-être aussi informée par mon propre parcours, je ne sais pas, du roman, c'est finalement,
la startup, c'est avant tout, le plus souvent en tout cas,
lancée par des gens qui ont le privilège, qui ont l'opportunité de le faire, qui sont donc, voilà, dans la capacité d'abandonner un boulot stable et de dire : « Ah bah j'ai encore des revenus de mes parents riches ».
Y a beaucoup ça en Belgique, la culture des familles très riches et tout ça. Et donc finalement, des gens très arrogants, très sûrs d'eux, très déconnectés en fait, voilà.
Et c'est souvent ça, j'ai l'impression, qui agace chez les startupers ou dans t--
on grossit le trait évidemment hein, mais dans l'ensemble, ce sont des gens déconnectés qui sont privilégiés, qui profitent du système. Voilà, 'fin,
un des startupers hommes qui, 'fin, ou même plusieurs des startupers hommes qui sont acteurs dans ton roman, ben sont coupables de harcèlement, de sexisme, de commentaires sexistes, de trucs à la-- voilà.
Et donc c'est la façon dont moi je l'ai lu, c'est finalement : « Ah bah voilà, la startup nation dans tout ce qu'elle a de plus méprisant, privilégié, arrogant,
et, tu vois, y a une certaine, une forme de mépris de classe, finalement, une forme de-
Mmh. Sur la question du harcèlement sexuel, donc effectivement un sujet que j'aborde dans le bouquin, c'est important pour moi de souligner que pour moi, c'est pas, encore une fois, c'est pas un problème de startup.
En fait, le truc, c'est que mon bouquin se passe sur un an. Je parle de la vie de quatre jeunes femmes sur un an.
Et en fait, c'est impossible pour moi d'écrire l'histoire de quatre jeunes femmes sur un an et qu'elles ne subissent aucun fait de sexisme.
C'est juste pas possible. C'est complètement irréaliste. C'est pas comme ça que ça se passe. C'est pas comme ça que ça se passe dans ma vie, dans celle de mes copines, et cetera.
Donc, donc ouais, pour moi, c'est un sujet qui se passe dans les startups, mais qui en même temps se passe complètement en dehors quoi.
Et je pense que c'est vrai pour pas mal d'autres sujets dans le sens où en fait le numérique, c'est la société, la société, c'est le numérique.
En tout cas, c'est la vision que j'ai des choses et que je pense qu'y a des choses,
y a des choses qu'on va peut-être attribuer aux startups, au numérique qui en fait sont plus des sujets de société en général dont on devrait réfléchir de manière plus générale.
'Fin, par exemple, quand on, pour revenir à Balance ta startup, voilà, où y a aussi des faits de harcèlement sexuel, et cetera, en fait, c'est des problèmes RH.
C'est vraiment des graves problèmes RH. Et que c'est pas parce que le milieu des startups est considéré comme à part qu'en fait, elle est exempte de bah du droit du travail en France, par exemple.
Donc moi, je vois beaucoup les choses comme étant interconnectées. Je sais pas si j'ai exactement répondu à ta question, mais je voulais quand même rebondir sur ce truc du harcèlement-
Tout à fait, donc c'était un rebondissement très utile. Mais qu'est-ce que tu as pensé peut-être de voilà, de ma lecture, de ma réflexion par rapport à-
Sur le mépris de classe, tu veux dire ?
Entre autres choses
...c'est intéressant comme question. Je pense qu'il y a un peu un côté, vous êtes avec nous ou contre nous.
Et notamment, je trouve que le milieu du numérique en général a un peu de mal avec la critique.
Mmh-mmh.
Ou avec la moquerie ou avec, et cetera.
Et on sait jamais où trop y a la limite. Par exemple, y a une newsletter que moi j'aime beaucoup qui s'appelle Tech Trash, qui est une newsletter française, qui parle de la startup nation et qui s'en moque pas mal.
Et par exemple, c'est une newsletter qui est assez populaire, 'fin en tout cas j'ai l'impression auprès de gens qui font la tech, parce que ça les fait marrer de, voilà, de rigoler un peu sur leur milieu.
Et en même temps, moi cette newsletter, honnêtement, elle me fait pas toujours rire. Au contraire, moi parfois, elle me désespère un petit peu parce que y a, voilà,
quand on voit une énième startup qui propose, j'en sais rien moi, des trucs un peu absurdes comme des toilettes connectées, des machines à jus de fruits, 'fin je sais-- et cetera.
Moi ça me fait pas rire. Ça fait un peu plombé l'ambiance de dire ça, mais c'est vrai que moi, je pense à l'état du monde, je pense à la planète, je pense à tout ça.
Et moi, je me dis : « Moi, j'ai plus trop le temps de rire de ça quoi ».
Mmh.
Donc c'est intéressant de réfléchir à ça, effectivement. Après, moi, y a un truc que je veux souligner, c'est que je reconnais que faire une startup, c'est super compliqué.
Et moi, j'ai rencontré plein d'entrepreneurs et d'entrepreneuses qui étaient, 'fin qui étaient des gens super courageux en fait hein, qui ont vraiment lancé des projets entrepreneuriaux qui étaient,
qui étaient assez dingues.
Et donc ces gens-là, je les méprise pas du tout, mais ce qui ne veut pas dire que je n'ai pas un problème avec le système qui les englobe quoi.
Et donc, tu parlais de l'exemple absurde des toilettes connectées. Ouais, je-- on a tous vu ces trucs-là de-- et d'ailleurs, t'en donnes un exemple dans le roman, c'est les startups dont le pitch, c'est :
on va donner des kits, des box pour boire, 'fin ou alors justement manger du fromage ou 'fin des kits pour les soirées, pour s'amuser, et cetera.
Les cocktails, les cocktails en kit.
Voilà, ce genre de trucs. Et on se dit : « Mais quel est le-- qui va acheter ça ? Mais pourquoi ? » 'fin c'est tellement déconnecté de la réalité.
Juste pour terminer ma réflexion, par rapport à donc cette startup nation qui peut parfois, ou en tout cas par certains moments être assez agaçante.
C'est-- j'ai le sentiment que, pour revenir sur cette idée qu'y a, voilà, cette caste très, très privilégiée,
y n'y a pas que ces personnes-là, bien sûr, mais,
mais j'ai le sentiment que souvent, on va voir dans la presse des personnes dont le but, finalement, c'est quelque chose de très-- 'fin très fort un marqueur de ma génération, je pense,
c'est l'idée d'un certain individualisme dans le sens où on veut se distinguer, on veut-- 'fin, et c'est une idée qui est exprimée dans le roman aussi, tracer son propre chemin.
Pas juste avoir un boulot stable, tranquille, bien payé. C'est : « Non, je veux me distinguer, je veux qu'on me remarque, je veux tracer mon propre chemin, changer le monde », voilà.
Et ça, c'est quelque chose de aussi très-- c'est un marqueur d'un privilège, finalement, de se dire : « Bah non, mon souci à moi, c'est pas payer mon loyer, payer mes factures.
C'est je veux être unique, je veux tracer mon propre chemin ».
Oui, je suis complètement d'accord là-dessus, le côté avoir un projet. C'est important d'avoir un projet, de le mener à bien, d'avoir du succès.
Et en plus, avoir un projet, généralement, avoir un projet, en fait, c'est avoir un projet commercial. C'est pas juste, je sais pas moi, avoir un projet, ça pourrait être,
j'sais pas moi, écrire des poèmes, apprendre à peindre.
'fin y a plein de gens qui ont plein de projets différents, mais ce qui est vachement valorisé par la société maintenant, je trouve, c'est avoir un projet qui soit généralement, en fait, une entreprise.
Une entreprise. Et ça va de l'entreprise dans son startup, comme, par exemple, moi, j'observe sur Internet le,
voilà, tout le mouvement autour de l'industrie de la création, la creator economy, 'fin l'influence.
Ou, alors ça fait un peu vieux con dire ça, mais c'est vrai que moi, j'ai connu un web dans lequel on créait pas mal gratuitement en fait pour tout le monde.
Voilà, moi j'ai beaucoup traîné dans les milieux des fanfictions, par exemple. Les fanfictions, c'est-
T'en parles beaucoup dans le livre, ouais.
Oui, oui, bah c'est parce que c'est un milieu, moi, qui me passionne. Et les fanfictions, c'est quelque chose d'assez altruiste, en fait, d'être une,
une personne qui écrit des ro-- littéralement des romans gratuitement pour tout le monde.
Et que maintenant, ce qui est plutôt, je trouve, valorisé en ligne, c'est davantage, voilà, les youtubeurs, les gens sur TikTok, les gens sur Instagram, les gens sur Twitch qui se font beaucoup d'argent,
'fin certains, en tout cas, très peu, mais certains,
se font beaucoup d'argent dans la création.
Et ça veut pas dire qu'ils ont tort de le faire. Ça veut pas dire que ce qu'ils font est moins sympathique, mais y a un peu ce côté, voilà, y a toujours la thune qui rentre en compte d'une manière ou d'une autre.
Et toujours voilà-
Mais la thune est là parce qu'ils ont des succès, parce qu'ils ont des millions de followers sur TikTok et qu'ensuite, ils peuvent faire des lives et recevoir de l'argent.
La thune, elle produit son succès.
La thune, il produit son succès, mais,
je pense aussi qu'y a, pour finir sur ce truc de la creator economy, y a vraiment cette espèce de truc agité par les plateformes elles-mêmes de dire : « Si tu t'investis à fond sur ton Twitch, par exemple-
Oui, c'est la finalité.
...tu vas te faire de l'argent ». Et du coup, je pense qu'y a aussi beaucoup de gens qui espèrent en fait, 'fin, de devenir riches et célèbres.
Alors, c'est vite dit hein, mais en tout cas pouvoir gagner sa vie grâce à ça. Et voilà, le projet est toujours un projet d'entreprise.
Et donc pour revenir à ta remarque, ouais, je suis d'accord, y a ce côté : « Nous, on l'a fait et pas toi ».
Alors qu'en fait, moi, je pense pas que, c'est pas parce que t'as pas un grand projet dans la vie, je sais pas moi, un projet d'entreprise, que t'es une personne moins intéressante, moins sympa, moins,
c'est un peu absurde comme manière de voir les choses.
Et par exemple, moi, y a un truc qui m'intéresse beaucoup en ce moment, c'est les mouvements de syndicalisation au sein de la Silicon Valley.
J'ai écrit pas mal là-dessus pour Libération. Donc en gros, notamment Google a un vrai mouvement en fait de ses employés qui cherchent à se syndiquer.
Et en fait, ça passe assez mal auprès de certaines personnes au sein de Google qui, jusqu'ici, voyaient un peu leur travail comme étant, voilà, on fait partie de cette grande famille.
Je mets des guillemets volontairement, une grande famille, en tout cas, ce grand projet Google. Sauf qu'en fait, à un moment, y a des employés qui ont dit : « Bah non.
En fait, c'est pas un projet, c'est une entreprise et moi j'suis employée.
Et moi j'suis pas d'accord avec la direction que prend ce fameux projet et du coup, je me sens en rupture vis-à-vis de ça.
Donc je cherche à me syndiquer. Et ça, c'est intéressant parce que du coup, on casse complètement le mythe, je trouve, du travailleur de la Silicon Valley qui est
passionné par son travail, parce que pour lui, c'est pas un travail, pour lui, il va changer le monde.
Et j'pense que ça, c'est pas forcément vrai et c'est sans doute de moins en moins vrai.
On a surtout parlé jusqu'à présent des startups, de la startup nation, etc. Mais évidemment, au centre de ton roman, y a avant tout une équipe de femmes, de leur vécu de femmes.
Et tu le disais, donc ça implique du harcèlement, du sexisme. À un moment donné dans le roman, on va pas dévoiler la fin de l'aventure.
Pas de spoiler.
Mais voilà. Mais l'équipe, voilà, une conversation avec une personne, une femme plus âgée.
Et la femme plus âgée les sermonne et leur dit : « Bah moi aussi, j'ai subi le racisme comme sans doute certaines filles de Rules », donc qui est donc le nom de la startup.
« Mais tu sais ce que j'ai fait ? J'ai fermé ma gueule, je me suis jamais énervée, j'ai avancé. J'imagine que vous pensez que c'est, que vous êtes dans votre bon droit, que c'est de la faute au sexisme, au capitalisme. Mais la vérité,
c'est que vous avez été nulles et naïves. » Est-ce qu'y a un,
un gouffre générationnel entre des femmes peut-être plus âgées qui ont juste accepté le système, accepté le sexisme tels qu'ils sont présents dans nos sociétés ?
Et peut-être des personnes plus jeunes qui vont plus avoir la volonté de remettre tout ça en question et de se positionner contre ce sexisme, ce racisme ?
Alors, j'vais pas prétendre faire des grandes vérités sur les générations parce que voilà, j'en suis pas capable hein, c'est pas mon métier.
C'est une question très dure, désolé.
Non, non, mais elle est intéressante parce qu'effectivement, donc le personnage dont tu parles, c'est Envy, qui est la directrice d'un incubateur.
Et pour moi, c'était important d'avoir ce personnage parce que en gros, j'voulais montrer que en fait, il était pas si évident de trouver sa voie et la manière de réagir face au sexisme dans un milieu professionnel.
Et qu'en fait, bah y a différentes méthodes pour y réagir. Y a différentes visions aussi des choses. Et que moi, je crois pas du tout en ce truc de dire : « Les femmes, elles font ça.
» Enfin, ça veut rien dire. Les femmes
enfin c'est un groupe cohérent dans le sens où on est identifiées par la société en tant que femmes, mais en fait, bah on est des individus et que on a différents vécus, différentes opinions, etc.
Et Envy, pour moi, ça représente, enfin, je voulais qu'elle représente un type de femmes qui acceptent le fait qu'elles sont dans un milieu avec beaucoup d'inégalités.
Elles le savent, elles sont pas naïves là-dessus, elles le subissent comme nous toutes, mais elles décident de jouer aux règles du jeu, respecter les règles du jeu, justement,
pour essayer de grimper le système de cette manière.
Donc voilà, c'est vrai qu'Envy, elle, son regard sur
cette situation, c'est de dire : « Bah si on t'insulte, tu souris, tu fermes les yeux et t'attends que ça passe et tu finiras par gagner puisque avec ta startup, tu finiras par grimper les échelons.
Et le plus important, c'est l'arrivée. C'est pas ce qui se passe avant quoi.
» Et ça, comme les héroïnes ne sont pas d'accord, mes héroïnes, elles sont effectivement plus jeunes, elles ont une vision beaucoup plus, voilà, pour elles, c'est pas acceptable de se faire traiter comme elles se font traiter.
Et j'essaye de pas avoir, enfin dans le roman, de pas exprimer d'opinion dans le sens où, enfin qui peut dire qui a raison ou qui a tort dans ces, j'pense que les femmes dans les milieux pro qui subissent du sexisme,
elles font ce qu'elles peuvent.
Elles font ce qu'elles peuvent et que parfois, on peut prendre une voie un peu plus radicale que d'autres et que parfois, bah il est plus intéressant de la jouer un peu plus profil bas.
Mais voilà, je, est-ce que c'est un gouffre générationnel ? J'en sais rien. Moi, dans ma carrière, j'ai vu des femmes plus âgées que moi qui étaient beaucoup plus vindicatives sur ces sujets.
J'ai vu des femmes de mon âge ou plus jeunes qui étaient plus, voilà, qui faisaient plus attention à ces sujets.
Mais en tout cas, c'était important pour moi d'expliquer que y a différentes manières de voir les choses.
Et ça me permettait aussi de questionner un peu un sujet pareil qui m'intéresse beaucoup, qui est celui de la girl boss, qu'on a beaucoup remis en cause ces dernières années, ces derniers mois.
Parce que donc la girl boss, c'est un peu ce mythe, c'est un peu la petite sœur ou la copine, je sais pas, de l'entrepreneur star.
C'est cette nana qui fonde une startup
qui a montré à tous ces hommes à quel point elle pouvait elle aussi monter une startup et qui du coup, en fait, reproduit complètement le modèle masculin, sauf que c'est une femme quoi.
Mais on est vraiment dans ce même modèle de l'entrepreneuriat par la force, l'entrepreneuriat par les journées à rallonge, la valorisation de l'épuisement, etc.
Et donc aux États-Unis, par exemple, y a eu pas mal de cas de startups fondées par des femmes, y compris des startups qui se voulaient assez féministes dans leur discours, qui en fait, bah
après les enquêtes journalistiques, on s'est rendu compte que c'était du flan et qu'en fait, au sein de la,
au sein de la startup, c'était horrible et,
et qui du coup, bah y avait une vraie dissonance entre les valeurs défendues par la boîte et les valeurs au sein de la boîte.
Et du coup, moi, c'était un truc que je voulais questionner, c'est que ma vision des choses, c'est que c'est pas parce qu'on met des femmes dans un milieu délétère que ce milieu d'un coup devient magiquement super.
Déjà un, parce que les femmes ont des défauts comme les hommes. Aussi parce que quand on parle de diversité dans la tech, on a tendance à réduire ce sujet à la femme blanche.
Et ça, c'est un sujet qui est important pour moi parce que moi, je suis une femme blanche et voilà, j'ai écrit ce bouquin, mais je pourrais pas représenter tous les vécus des femmes minorisées, en fait.
Et que y a des vrais sujets aussi qui sont très peu abordés, qui ont plus trait aux femmes racisées, aux femmes handicapées, etc.
Donc voilà, réponse longue, mais oui, oui, c'est un personnage qui était important pour moi pour
montrer un peu que c'était pas un, c'est pas un problème qui est facile à résoudre en fait et c'est pas un problème qui est facile
à appréhender.
On l'a évoqué aussi tout à l'heure, donc les startupeuses de Rules, à un moment donné, donc font un peu de presse sur Internet, se font connaître et y a une réaction immédiate qui est le cyberharcèlement.
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose auquel tu as toi-même eu l'occasion d'être confrontée en tant que journaliste ? Puisque pour, voilà, connaître des femmes journalistes dans mon entourage proche, c'est assez automatique, assez important,
toutes les horreurs qu'elles se prennent.
Et oui, est-ce que c'était inévitable pour toi
quand quatre femmes lancent un produit consacré aux technologies autour du cycle menstruel, c'était inévitable, automatique que le cyberharcèlement allait prendre place ?
La réponse courte, oui.
Mmh.
La réponse longue, c'est que oui, oui, moi, j'ai subi du cyberharcèlement. Alors, j'ai la chance de, 'fin, j'ai la chance, j'ai pas subi autant que certaines de mes consœurs ont pu subir.
Mais moi, y a un truc qui m'a beaucoup marquée dans ma carrière et que j'ai déjà raconté, mais lors de ma deuxième ou troisième année, je crois, d'activité, donc au Figarotech,
j'ai écrit un article sur, à l'époque, c'était Ellen Pao qui venait de prendre la direction de Reddit.
Tout à fait, ouais.
Voilà, donc y avait tout un sujet, bah justement sur le racisme et le sexisme des utilisateurs et utilisatrices de Reddit.
Parce qu'elle s'était elle-même pris beaucoup de, de d'insultes en fait quand elle a pris ce poste.
Y avait des subreddits qui avaient été fermés et toute la faute de cette nouvelle direction était mise sur elle et elle était le changement négatif, etc. C'était-
Mmh, voilà, c'est ça. Et donc vu qu'on est incapable de critiquer des femmes sans mentionner le fait qu'elles sont des femmes, bah elle s'en était pris, voilà.
Donc je, j'écris un article assez classique, comme j'en ai écrit 1 000 au Figarotech. Je le publie et, pour une raison que j'ignore, je suis repérée par un type
que je vais pas citer, mais voilà, qui était un type à l'époque qui avait une petite audience sur sa page Facebook.
Et donc, qui a une page Facebook et qui cite mon article.
J'ai plus les termes exacts, mais en gros, qui m'insulte et qui me dise, 'fin, qui me traite sans doute de gauchiste, de j'sais pas quoi et qui finit en tout cas
par conclure : « Bon ben, pour la punir, je vous propose de faire un concours de montage pornographique avec sa tronche. »
Ouf.
Voilà.
D'accord, oui.
Donc, alors, la chance que j'ai eue dans mon malheur, c'est que les internautes qui le suivaient étaient pas très bons en Photoshop, donc j'ai pas eu grand-chose, mais-
C'est triste comme anecdote le-
Ah oui, non, mais c'est désespérant en fait c'est-
La chance que tu as eue.
Mais en fait, c'est, moi, maintenant, je le raconte de manière assez tranquille, mais en fait à l'époque, ça a été extrêmement choquant.
Oui.
Parce que, bah déjà un, moi, j'étais entourée, alors, au Figarotech, il se trouve qu'on était pas mal de femmes, donc j'étais pas du tout la seule femme dans ma rubrique.
Mais, voilà, c'est vrai que c'était quelque chose auquel j'étais pas du tout préparée, auquel je m'attendais pas.
J'ai pas su comment réagir. J'ai essayé de le signaler à Facebook. Facebook n'a pas voulu le retirer au départ, en disant que ça ne contrevenait pas, pardon, à ses règles.
'Fin bon, et donc ça, c'est qu'un exemple, mais oui, le cyberharcèlement, c'est une réalité, quand on est une femme sur Internet.
C'est une réalité encore plus quand on est une femme publique. Et c'est encore pire quand on est une femme publique qui ne rentre pas dans les cases de ce qu'on attend d'une femme.
Donc c'est-à-dire si on n'est pas hétéro, si on n'est pas blanche, si, voilà, on n'est pas fine. 'Fin tout ça, c'est des armes supplémentaires pour vous en foutre plein la gueule.
Donc oui, de la même manière que pour moi, c'était inconcevable d'écrire une histoire sur quatre femmes pendant un an et de ne pas mentionner le sexisme en général.
Pour moi, quatre femmes qui lancent une start-up,
qui utilisent les réseaux sociaux et qui en plus, leur start-up a pour sujet les règles, moi, c'était évident qu'il fallait qu'à un moment, je mentionne ces faits de cyberharcèlement quoi.
Donc voilà, c'est pas un truc qui est très, enfin si en fait, c'est quand même assez important dans le roman, mais-
Mmh.
Mais voilà, ça me paraissait important de parler de ce sujet et d'expliquer en quoi c'est très banal aussi.
Malheureusement, c'est quand même banalisé dans nos vies, et qu'il y a très peu de recours, y a très peu de recours face à ça.
'Fin, les filles dans ma start-up, elles, dans ma start-up
les filles dans la start-up de fiction que j'ai écrite, elles hésitent à porter plainte, puis elles le font pas comme des millions de femmes tout le temps, parce qu'en fait, effectivement,
dans beaucoup des cas, ça ne sert à pas grand-chose.
Et donc, on parlait
du cyberharcèlement et en particulier donc des femmes journalistes. Je peux conseiller, je ne sais pas si tu l'as vu, l'excellent documentaire Sale Pute qui est fait par mes bonnes amies, Myriam Leroy et Florence Hainaut. Et j'étais-
J'allais en parler.
J'étais juste, ben voilà, les grands esprits se rencontrent. J'étais justement au procès de Myriam contre son harceleur, la semaine dernière.
Mais oui, donc c'est comme tu le dis, absolument prégnant et omniprésent quand les femmes sont en ligne.
Et c'est une réalité dont on se rend pas compte, j'pense. De la même manière que, en France en tout cas, quand on a commencé à beaucoup parler du harcèlement de rue, 'fin, qu'on a commencé à trouver ce terme de harcèlement de rue,
moi, j'avais beaucoup de réactions de proches masculins qui me disaient
: « Mais c'est vrai ?
Ça se passe vraiment comme ça quand vous allez dans la rue ? » Et parce qu'ils se rendaient pas compte en fait de ce qui se passait.
Alors, ils s'en rendaient pas compte, puis j'pense aussi qu'ils nous écoutaient pas quand on en parlait. Ou alors, ils rangeaient ça comme un truc un peu exceptionnel.
Alors que pour moi, le harcèlement de rue, c'est pas un truc exceptionnel, c'est un bruit de fond en fait. C'est terrible hein, mais c'est un truc constant qui t'arrive tout le temps, que t'as tout le temps en tête quand tu sors.
Et c'est pareil pour le cyberharcèlement. Pour moi, le cyberharcèlement, c'est pas exceptionnel, c'est banal, c'est systémisé.
Et en fait, c'est un bruit de fond constant et du coup, on en vient à avoir un peu le--
par exemple, un truc que mes copines et moi, on faisait à un moment, 'fin, on disait qu'on le faisait, c'était de rentrer chez soi seules, on mettait nos clés entre nos mains.
C'est un peu cette astuce qu'on se filait entre copines, pour se dire, bah voilà, si on a besoin de frapper quelqu'un, on le frappe avec les clés, ça fait plus mal.
Alors, je sais même pas si c'est vrai ou pas, mais c'est un peu cette légende urbaine qu'on se passait entre filles.
Et je me rends compte que je reproduis un peu ce système de la clé, mais sur Internet, voilà, en prenant des précautions que je vais pas citer, du coup, pour pas qu'on, pour pas qu'on-
D'accord, OK.
...qu'on m'emmerde. Mais y a des trucs que je fais de manière un peu inconsciente que, mais que je fais très clairement pour me protéger du cyberharcèlement.
Et en même temps, ça m'emmerde de devoir prendre ces précautions alors que, il suffirait. Si seulement les hommes ne harcelaient pas, ça serait plus simple.
Tu parlais de la réaction des hommes. Souvent, le conseil, d'après ce qu'on a pu m'expliquer, souvent, le conseil que les hommes donnent à ce moment-là, c'est de faire comme si de rien n'était et de mettre ça de côté, etc.
Mais précisément parce qu'en fait, ils ont du mal à concevoir et à se rendre compte à quel point c'est impactant et omniprésent.
Et voilà, on a du mal à mettre ça de côté. Et l'autre truc qui a été très révélateur, je sais pas si c'est le bon mot, mais pour moi, c'est quand j'avais interviewé Marie Peltier
et qu'elle expliquait que plutôt que de--
'fin, que quand elle se prenait des vagues de harcèlement sur Twitter et qu'on l'emmerdait,
plutôt que d'avoir des hommes qui viennent la voir après en disant : « Oh, mais nous, on t'aime bien et on aime bien ton travail » et tout ça.
Mais elle disait qu'elle n'en avait rien à foutre et que ce qu'elle voulait, c'était justement des hommes qui allaient un peu les remettre à leur place plutôt que de juste rester silencieux, rester passifs sur le côté pendant que ça se passe.
Et c'est vrai que, bah en fait, ça, je l'ai jamais fait. Genre quand je vois un comportement dégueulasse prendre place, genre me jeter, m'interjecter dans le truc.
Mais parce que, en fait, je suis tellement peureux, en fait. Genre j'ai pas envie de toucher à ça.
Mh. Bah, je pense que le plus important dans le cyberharcèlement, c'est d'abord de demander à la victime ce qu'elle veut.
Parce que, de la même manière que les femmes ne pensent pas toutes de la même manière, les victimes de cyberharcèlement n'ont pas toutes les mêmes envies, je pense.
Et c'est marrant parce que, 'fin, c'est marrant, non, c'est pas drôle du tout, mais il se trouve que j'ai écrit sur le sujet y a pas très longtemps, pour ma newsletter, donc Règle 30 chez Numerama.
J'ai écrit justement sur ces affaires de cyberharcèlement. On a un peu l'impression de cette répétition encore et encore.
On, chaque jour, on en apprend des nouvelles et à chaque fois, on est choqué, mais à chaque fois, on revient de la même manière.
Et y a un peu cette réaction bête que tout le monde a, parce que c'est un peu l'un de ces vieux adages sur Internet, qui est bien intentionné, mais qui est un peu stupide, qui est : « Don't feed the troll ».
Donc ça, c'est un truc qu'on dit beaucoup aux filles qui se font harceler. Je dis : « Oui, mais c'est les trolls, donc si tu leur réponds pas, ils disparaîtront ».
Déjà un, moi, j'en ai marre qu'on me parle de troll quand en fait, on parle de harceleur. Donc moi, je pense que... j'estime que le mot troll a été perdu, pour toujours,
et qu'il a été contaminé et qu'en fait, la culture du trolling telle qu'on l'a connue à une époque n'existe plus.
Et encore, je pense qu'à une époque aussi, c'était déjà du harcèlement. Et qu'en fait, ne pas répondre, déjà un, on n'en a pas forcément les capacités.
C'est pas forcément évident de disparaître de la surface de la Terre. Typiquement, quand on est journaliste, faut bien qu'on existe, en fait.
Faut bien qu'on ait une présence médiatique. On peut pas juste faire comme si rien ne se passait. Et puis, en fait, ça ne marche pas.
'Fin, je veux dire, quand on regarde un peu les travaux de recherche
sur les trolls, en fait, le troll, il cherche une réaction, mais il cherche une réaction jusqu'au bout, c'est-à-dire que s'il l'a pas, il va continuer à la chercher encore et encore et encore.
Donc, « don't feed the troll », je trouve pas ça très intelligent. Moi, ce que je trouve plus intéressant, par exemple, c'est de réfléchir à qui troll et pourquoi.
Et je veux dire, là pareil, quand on regarde les études, le trolling est quand même un comportement qui est assez masculin.
Pourquoi les hommes trollent ? C'est une question que je me pose parfois.
Ah ouais ? C'est une question rhétorique ou bien t'as une idée dans la tête ?
Oh, moi, je suis pas chercheuse, hein, donc j'ai pas fait d'études sociologiques sur le sujet ni rien, mais bon, je trouve ça quand même intéressant.
On approche tou... ah oui, donc juste, je ne sais pas si je l'avais précisé. Donc le documentaire Sale Pute, toujours dispo sur YouTube, sur la chaîne de Arte.
On approche tout doucement du bout des 70 minutes. On n'a pas encore parlé de l'autre sujet principal de ce roman, à savoir la menstruation.
Mh.
Donc, tu expliquais que c'est un sujet qui t'intéresse depuis même avant la rédaction de ce roman, que t'as écrit, tu as écrit là-dessus, tu as,
tu as couvert l'actualité de ces menstrutech, voilà, dans ton travail journalistique, tu as enregistré des podcasts à ce sujet.
What about it ? Qu'est-ce qui t'intéresse particulièrement ?
Alors, déjà, c'est bêtement, c'est un sujet qui m'intéresse parce que j'ai mes règles et que j'ai un smartphone.
D'accord.
Donc voilà, on va...
Bonne raison.
...on va commencer par là. En fait, moi, la menstrutech, c'est un milieu qui me fascine parce que je trouve que c'est un milieu qui comporte à la fois des enjeux féministes et des enjeux éthiques.
Déjà féministe parce que, donc grosso merdo, la moitié de la population a ses règles une fois par mois. On va faire très, très gros, mais voilà.
Et pourtant, c'est un sujet qui a vraiment tardé à être abordé par les nouvelles technologies et les applications.
La santé connectée, c'est un domaine qui est investi par les géants de la tech depuis très longtemps.
Et en fait, la menstrutech, 'fin les menstruations, c'est quelque chose qui a mis vachement de temps en fait, à être envisagé par Apple, par exemple, qui a une application de suivi de santé.
On a attendu un an après la sortie de l'application de santé pour avoir un truc sur les règles, etc. Donc,
pour moi, c'était un sujet qui était assez symbolique, qui représentait bien en fait le manque de femmes dans ces milieux de la tech.
C'est-à-dire que oui, si on met 15 mecs dans une salle et qu'on leur demande de réfléchir à la santé, ils vont davantage penser à la santé qui les concerne et pas celle des autres.
Donc voilà, ça, c'est un sujet qui m'intéresse pas mal.
C'est le produit d'un manque de diversité...
Oui, voilà, très clairement. Et d'ailleurs,
moi, j'avais interviewé, à l'époque où j'étais au Figaro, Ida Tin, qui est une entrepreneuse, donc qui a lancé une application qui s'appelle Clue, qui est l'une des grosses applications de menstrutech, qui est d'origine allemande.
Et elle, elle racontait bien à quel point elle avait vachement de mal à lever des fonds, à intéresser les fonds, en fait.
Elle venait les voir en leur disant : « J'ai ce truc et je pense que c'est important.
» Et on lui disait : « Ah bon ? Pourquoi ? » Bon. Donc y a ce côté-là. Après, y a aussi des sujets éthiques qui moi m'intéressent beaucoup.
Déjà,
c'est pas parce qu'on fait une application de menstruation qu'on fait une application féministe. Y a plein de manières de le faire et y a pas mal de manières,
'fin, délétères, assez questionnables, en tout cas, de le faire.
Typiquement, y a beaucoup d'applications de menstruation, de menstrutech qui sont autour de la procréation.
C'est-à-dire, c'est des aides en fait à la... oui, c'est des aides à la procréation. Donc on va suivre nos menstruations pour savoir quand est-ce qu'on va ovuler et avoir des rapports sexuels pour avoir un enfant.
Donc, là, voilà, on met un peu plus la femme dans un carcan qui est celui de : tu dois devenir une maman.
Mmh.
La femme cis, hein, évidemment, parce que beaucoup d'applications de menstrutech ne prennent pas du tout en compte le fait que y a des femmes cis qui ont pas leurs règles et y a des femmes trans qui n'ont pas leurs règles non plus.
Des hommes trans qui ont leurs règles.
Et des hommes trans qui ont leurs règles, tout à fait.
Et puis après, y a toute la question des données. Parce que, mine de rien, les données relatives aux règles, les données relatives au corps en général, c'est des données qui sont très personnelles, qui sont très sensibles et qui...
moi, ce que j'ai souvent, c'est que le modèle économique des applications de menstrutech n'est pas pire que les autres applications, hein.
C'est des applications, voilà, qui font de la pub. Sauf que les données sont assez différentes. C'est-à-dire que peut-être qu'on s'en fiche, je sais pas, moi.
L'exemple que je donne souvent, c'est Spotify. Je devrais peut-être pas, mais moi, personnellement, le fait que Spotify connaisse mes goûts musicaux, je m'en fous un peu.
Ça reste sans doute problématique pour pas mal de gens, mais moi, je m'en fous. Par contre,
que le service de publicitaire de Google sache quand j'ai mes règles, quand j'ai des rapports sexuels, etc., ça, ça m'embête davantage.
Et moi, je fais le pari un peu pessimiste que ce qui est en train de se passer avec la menstrutech,
dans son développement, dans, voilà, au niveau publicitaire, au niveau de ses relations avec les mutuelles aussi aux États-Unis, c'est quelque chose qui va se passer aussi avec la santé connectée en général.
Et en Europe aussi ? Tu penses que ça va s'importer ici ?
Alors, en Europe, on a la chance d'avoir le RGPD. On a la chance d'avoir quand même une vision, en fait, de l'exploitation des données qui est très différente de celle américaine.
Oui.
Ce qui nous sauve pas de tout, mais quand même, on a
un... typiquement, moi, j'avais été fascinée, j'avais parlé avec une nana qui utilisait une application de menstrutech aux États-Unis
et qui l'utilisait en fait dans le cadre de son entreprise, son entreprise qui lui avait proposé de, voilà,
de suivre ses règles.
Et d'ailleurs, ça a fait l'objet d'un article dans le Washington Post, ce truc. Et en gros, c'est une appli de menstrutech et qui redonnait en fait à l'entreprise des données anonymisées sur le nombre de femmes,
employées qui souhaitaient avoir un enfant.
Donc en gros, l'idée, c'était de dire : « Oui, mais c'est utile parce que si l'entreprise sait combien de pourcentages d'employés veulent un enfant,
du coup, on peut leur donner une couverture santé mieux adaptée.
» Sauf que ça pose quand même des vraies, 'fin, des vraies questions. 'Fin, moi, en tout cas, ça me questionne de : est-ce qu'on a envie que nos entreprises sachent si on veut avoir un enfant ou pas ?
Même si c'est anonymisé, ça reste quand même un domaine de vie privée. On sait aussi, voilà, on connaît bien les sujets de discrimination envers les femmes qui veulent avoir des enfants, etc.
Bon, ça, c'est pas possible en France. Néanmoins, je pense que c'est important de s'interroger sur ces sujets et de les examiner, parce que déjà, un, les boîtes respectent pas toujours les règles en vigueur.
Et de voilà... 'fin, honnêtement, je pourrais tenir 70 minutes de plus sur ce sujet. Moi, c'est un sujet qui, voilà, qui me...
Oui, tout à fait. On sent la passion. Mais justement, la question à la base, c'était : mais finalement, des personnes qui ont leurs règles et qui ont un smartphone, je peux en trouver plein,
une personne sur deux presque.
'Fin non, je sais pas si une personne sur deux a un smartphone, mais tu m'auras compris.
Bref.
Oui. Et du coup, mais du coup, oui, mais tu es finalement la seule qui en parle autant ou, 'fin, que...
tu vois ? Ça, ça a attrapé ta passion et ça ne l'a jamais lâchée depuis quelques années.
Alors, y a d'autres personnes, hein, qui écrivent sur ces sujets. En France, par exemple, y a une chercheuse dont j'aime beaucoup le travail, qui s'appelle Marion Coville.
Bien sûr.
Que tu connais, ouais, super, qui fait beaucoup de recherches aussi sur la menstrutech. Je pense aussi que c'est un sujet qui a tardé à être abordé par les médias.
Et là, on en revient aux inégalités dans notre traitement de la tech.
D'accord.
Parce que je pense que c'était vu comme un peu un non-sujet. Moi, je me rappelle, la première fois que j'ai pitché un sujet sur la menstrutech auprès de mon chef au Figaro,
il a pas du tout eu une réaction négative, hein.
Il m'a pas dit : « Ah, tu me parles des règles, machin. » Non, non, il est resté très pro, mais il m'a dit : « Mais en fait, à quoi ça sert cette app ?
Genre, à quoi ça vous sert ? »
Quel public pour ce sujet, la menstruation ? Qui est-ce que ça concerne ?
Et en fait, c'était pas tant ça, c'était qu'il avait du mal à comprendre pourquoi est-ce que les femmes avaient besoin d'une application,
D'accord.
...pour suivre les règles quoi. Et donc...
Oui, c'est... la question est posée aussi dans le roman, c'est : mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut pas juste employer le calendrier ?
Voilà, ou un calendrier ou juste...
je pense aussi qu'y a des gens qui pensent que les femmes ont une sorte d'alarme dans la tête qui dit : « Tut, tut,
c'est l'heure des règles » et les règles arrivent quoi, alors que en fait, dans les faits, c'est pas forcément le cas.
Et après, moi, voilà, je l'ai toujours dit, je suis utilisatrice de ces services. Y a plein de femmes qui les utilisent pas et c'est... moi, je n'encourage ni l'un ni l'autre.
Moi, je pense juste que c'est un milieu qui est à la croisée de plein de sujets importants, pour les femmes, mais aussi pour la tech, et pour, voilà, la santé connectée.
Et c'est pour ça que je m'y suis intéressée quoi.
Oui. Est-ce que je peux juste revenir en arrière ? Tu avais mentionné donc une affaire en Amérique du Nord qui s'était terminée sur un article du Washington Post.
Alors, en 2019, le Washington Post sort un article sur une application qui s'appelle Ovia. Ovia, c'est une application de menstrutech qui est plutôt orientée sur la procréation.
C'est-à-dire qu'en gros, on l'utilise pour essayer de tomber enceinte et pour suivre ensuite sa grossesse. Et en gros, cet article, ce qu'il expliquait, c'était que
cette application était parfois proposée par des entreprises à leurs employés.
C'est-à-dire que en plus de la mutuelle, en gros, on leur disait : « Voilà, si vous avez des désirs d'enfants, etc., vous pouvez utiliser Ovia.
» Et le deal, en gros, c'était : si vous utilisez Ovia, donc gratuitement grâce à la mutuelle de l'entreprise,
vous acceptez que vos données, de manière anonyme, mais quand même vos données, soient récupérées et transmises à votre entreprise.
L'idée, en gros, dans cette histoire, c'est de dire
: en ayant des données assez précises sur les désirs de grossesse au sein de l'entreprise, l'entreprise peut prendre des meilleures décisions sur la couverture de santé qui peut être proposée,
à ses employés.
Donc, par exemple, j'en sais rien, moi, si
70 % de mes employés veulent avoir un enfant, peut-être que j'ai plus intérêt à proposer une mutuelle avec des bons bénéfices en termes d'avoir des enfants que si y en a que 20 %.
Donc, c'est un système qui est assez, 'fin qui fait sens, en tout cas, dans un contexte américain où, voilà, la santé est privatisée, coûte très cher, etc.
Mais ce que l'article posait, c'est que c'était, voilà, un vrai sujet de vie privée et aussi de données.
C'est-à-dire que, par exemple, y avait des utilisatrices qui avaient pas tout à fait conscience, en fait, que leurs entreprises pouvaient concrètement savoir si elles avaient un enfant ou pas.
Alors, l'entreprise ne savait pas si, j'sais pas moi, mademoiselle Michu voulait un enfant et mademoiselle Michou n'en voulait pas.
Mais y avait quand même cette histoire d'exploitation des données très intimes, pour une raison très spécifique.
Voilà. Et donc ça, c'est un exemple, en fait, je trouve, de ce qui devrait nous inquiéter, en tout cas nous interpeller, je pense, sur le traitement de nos données de santé.
Voilà, en France, on a la chance, pour le moment, d'avoir un système de santé qui est très différent de ce qui se passe aux États-Unis.
Après, y a un vrai business qui est en train de se construire autour des données connectées. Y a un bouquin qui est sorti à ce sujet qui s'appelle : « Ma santé, mes données », par une consœur qui s'appelle Coralie Lemke.
Et c'est un bouquin qui, voilà, parle justement de ça, de cette or noir que sont nos données de santé.
Et en fait, on se rend pas compte que... on a tendance à penser que la santé, 'fin les données de santé sont très protégées, impossibles d'y accéder, etc.
La crise du COVID a prouvé que ce n'était pas du tout le cas, que déjà, un,
notre santé pouvait tout à fait être transformée en données et qu'elles étaient déjà en fait connues par, voilà, par des institutions, par des médecins, par des entreprises, etc.
Et qu'en fait, ce futur un peu de SF sombre dans lequel, j'sais pas moi, une entreprise sait
quel est mon poids, quelle est ma taille, quel est mon pouls cardiaque, quelles sont mes maladies, etc., il est pas si lointain que ça et qu'il faut y être attentif.
Et ça passe aussi, voilà, ça passe par les mutuelles, ça passe aussi par le milieu de la pub.
Y a une histoire que je raconte tout le temps, mais que moi, je trouve vachement emblématique.
En 2015, le New York Times a publié un édito d'une femme qui explique que elle avait utilisé une application de menstrutech, alors aux États-Unis.
L'application n'est pas citée, mais c'est aux États-Unis. Donc elle utilise ces applications parce qu'elle veut avoir un enfant.
Elle finit par tomber enceinte, donc elle le signale à l'application. Donc elle commence à avoir, voilà, son enfant qui grandit, etc.
Et malheureusement, elle perd le bébé, 'fin elle perd ce fœtus.
Elle fait une fausse couche.
Donc elle fait une fausse couche. Donc y a un événement extrêmement banal, en fait, et assez classique, malheureusement, dans les grossesses.
Et donc, elle a une réaction assez naturelle qui est de... elle supprime en fait l'application de son smartphone et puis, elle passe à autre chose. Elle fait
son deuil ou pas d'ailleurs, mais en tout cas, elle passe à autre chose.
Et six mois après cet événement, la fausse couche,
elle reçoit devant chez elle un joli petit paquet, avec des couches, avec du lait en poudre et en gros, un petit,
une petite carte en disant : « Félicitations pour la naissance de votre enfant », bla bla bla.
Donc, qu'est-ce qui s'était passé ? En fait, en acceptant d'utiliser cette application, en fait, elle avait, sans le savoir,
accepté l'exploitation de ses données, y compris auprès des partenaires commerciaux de l'application.
Et donc, assez bêtement, l'application avait déduit que, neuf mois après le fait d'avoir déclaré être enceinte, elle a accouché, donc on va lui envoyer un colis des partenaires.
Et parce qu'elle n'avait pas créé la donnée propre à la fausse couche, elle n'avait pas fait de sa fausse couche une donnée.
Ce qui était possible, j'imagine.
Ce qui était possible.
Mais c'est peut-être pas le premier réflexe qu'elle a eu après sa fausse couche.
Oui, voilà. C'est juste qu'elle a arrêté en fait d'utiliser l'application, puis elle l'a retirée, ce qui me paraît assez normal en fait, comme acte.
Elle a reçu ce colis. Donc c'est une histoire, mais en fait, ces applications, un, elles sont super intrusives et deux, en fait, elles ont vachement de mal à prendre en compte plein de choses de la vie.
Typiquement, les femmes qui ont de l'endométriose ont du mal à utiliser les applications de menstrutech parce qu'en fait, elles ont souvent des cycles très irréguliers.
Mmh. Une barre de 10.
Voilà, c'est vachement fréquent. De la même manière, les avortements sont pas des événements qu'on peut typiquement déclarer, en fait, dans une application de menstrutech.
On peut pas dire : « J'ai avorté. » Alors qu'en fait, les avortements sont des événements qui vont perturber souvent le cycle menstruel.
Donc, y a plein de sujets sur la normativité...
Ouais, c'est ça, c'est le bon mot, la normativité, le-
La normativité-
Le trait dogmatique, voilà.
...qu'induisent en fait ces applications. Et encore une fois, là, on parle des menstruations, mais moi, je pense que malheureusement, c'est quelque chose qui peut arriver avec plein d'autres applications de santé connectée.
Et la norme, c'est rarement une bonne chose en santé. Or, les applications, les IA, etc., fonctionnent à partir de normes.
Et ça, ça induit des biais. Et moi, c'est un sujet sur lequel non seulement ça m'intéresse, mais sur lequel je veux alerter.
C'est absolument fascinant. Après, faut quand même préciser que les biais et la normativité, malheureusement, existent aussi auprès des gynécologues qui, voilà, qui ne sont pas des intelligences artificielles.
Et dans la vie en général. Ça, c'est-- moi, je crois pas au technosolutionnisme, mais je crois pas non plus au technoscepticisme.
Je veux dire, c'est pas à cause de la tech qu'on devient, je sais pas moi, raciste, sexiste ou bête.
Enfin, je veux dire, la tech est le miroir déformant de la société, mais il faut la société d'abord en fait, pour faire la tech.
Nous sommes bien d'accord. C'est une magnifique conclusion. Tu fais très bien ça. Mais donc on arrive malheureusement au bout des Septante Minutes.
Est-ce que tu peux dire aux auditeurs, aux auditrices où on peut te retrouver ?
Oui, tout à fait. Alors le plus simple, c'est de me suivre sur Twitter, @LucieRonfaut. J'y parle de mes différents articles, mes différents travaux.
Et puis sinon, si ce que je vous ai dit vous intéresse, pardon. Ça m'intéresse moi a priori, j'espère.
Vous suivez ma newsletter, vous tapez Règle 30 Numerama ou Lucie Ronfaut Numerama sur votre moteur de recherche préféré et vous tomberez sur ma newsletter.
C'est tous les mercredis à 11 h.
Et pour celles et ceux qui sont amateurs, amatrices de podcast, comme on se doute, on espère que vous l'êtes. Tu as également produit ou réalisé un podcast il y a peu, qui s'appelle La solitude du modo.
Tout à fait. Ouais, je collabore assez régulièrement avec Bing Audio, donc je leur ai fait trois podcasts. Et mon dernier, c'est La solitude du modo,
qui est une série d'entretiens croisés avec des modérateurs et des modératrices sur Internet.
Sur les réseaux sociaux, sur les forums, voilà.
Voilà, tout à fait.
Les gens qui doivent justement gérer les trolls.
Tout à fait.
Voilà. Mais c'est formidable. Je mettrai tous les liens dans la description. Et Lucie, je te remercie beaucoup d'avoir passé Septante Minutes avec moi.
Merci beaucoup.
Et on vous dit à dans deux semaines pour un prochain épisode. Au revoir.
Au revoir.
Voilà, c'est déjà tout pour ces Septante Minutes. Un grand merci à Lucie pour sa présence et pour son expertise sur tous ces sujets.
J'ai mis tous les liens dans la description vers son Twitter, sa newsletter, La Règle 30, son livre Les règles du jeu, ainsi que ses podcasts.
Je vous remercie d'avoir écouté. Pour celles et ceux qui découvrent Septante Minutes Avec, n'hésitez pas à aller regarder les épisodes précédents.
On en est déjà au cinquante-et-unième, mine de rien. Vous pourrez retrouver mes interviews avec par exemple le directeur de Google Belgique, avec Alice Coffin.
On a cité à un moment donné le docu Sale Pute réalisé par Myriam Leroy et Florence Hainaut. Et elles ont aussi eu droit à leur épisode de Septante Minutes Avec.
Donc allez-y, faites le pas. Abonnez-vous à Septante Minutes Avec sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée et sur les réseaux sociaux, vous ne le regretterez pas.
Et allez, quant à moi, je vous dis à très bientôt. Salut salut !